i found uh this distinguished i found in
nice guys and so i'm sure it's true and
nice girls as well there are two types
of nice guys one is the i call it i'm so
good nice guy the other is the i'm so
bad nice guy i fit no i'm so good nice
guy category i think i do everything so
well everybody should think i'm great
now
deep down inside in this really dark
tightly locked box is my toxic shame
that i work really hard to avoid ever
having to feel or experience the sense
that i'm not okay that's why i work so
hard to be good is because deep inside i
don't feel okay that's the i'm so good
nice guy if everybody got to know me
everybody would love me now i'm so bad
nice guy is often the guy that started
rebelling or acting out oppositionally
defiant behavior at a young age maybe
start drinking doing pot dropped out of
school you know [ __ ] up a lot and then
maybe you know got married or had a kid
or found jesus or he got in the military
and they got their life in order but now
they're trying to be a nice guy but deep
inside they still think if anybody gets
gets close to me they're going to find
out how messed up i really am so that's
i'm so bad nice guy
so
by finding a safe person a coach a
therapist a group a 12-step program a
minister rabbi whatever
and beginning to reveal yourself you
begin to release toxic shame
and that that is so so unburdening so
liberating and you start getting more
accurate feedback from a safe person as
to who you really are yeah
and you might say before i'll give you
an example i i was leading a men's
workshop several years ago and there's a
guy in there
um
early 40s african-american
and he just carried so much toxic shame
and so during this workshop i just asked
him
what what is your deepest
shame shameful thing about you and he
told a story that when he was like 14 he
stole a car stereo
and because of that ever since he's just
believed he's the most terrible human
being and like all the other men in this
workshop looked at him it was a small
group about 810 guys and they said
really that's it
we all did stupid stuff when we were 14.
you know that that's that's probably
small change and like he got accurate
information that doing a stupid 14 year
old thing did not make him a horrible
person and that was that one thing was
just liberating to him to he he could
quit beating himself up for being this
terrible person so we get more accurate
feedback as to who we are
by by revealing ourselves to safe people
we also get to practice being honest and
that was such a big thing for me nice
guys think we're you know we're so great
we're so this we're so that you know we
you know give us a parade give us
confetti whatever but the truth is most
guys most nice guys are extremely
dishonest we only reveal what what we
think you know you want to hear we hide
anything that might get the negative
reaction we we twist the truth we leave
it out we embellish it we misdirect your
attention and so one of the first things
i realized i had to do
was just start being an honest person so
being in a safe environment
let me practice telling my entire truth
with people that weren't going to like
overreact or
abandon me that then let me begin
practicing it with the people who i was
most afraid of overreacting or
abandoning me
family partner
close friends
and so having that safe place lets us
release shame get more accurate
information of who we are and alyssa's
practice being a more honest person so
that is where i recommend people start
this is so interesting okay i'm very
glad i had you on i had a great time
with like adam lane
smith i was like this all makes sense
that's so interesting so this is very
cool so that's why uh al-anon
is such a huge thing right because you
connect with somebody and who cares if
like what's the risk of telling them
your deepest darkest secrets it's not
like your family right they're not
necessarily going to care
yeah and you know and i'll tell you a
short story um
when i was like early in this process i
i was in this 12-step group and i had a
therapist a female therapist
and um
pretty early on i i had a dark sexual
impulse i didn't act on it but just the
fact that i noticed myself having this
dark impulse really scared me now the
old previous me
probably never would have let that
impulse even get into conscious
awareness but when it did because i was
practicing letting stuff come into
conscious awareness
it scared me it scared me i didn't act
on it and that felt good but it felt bad
that i even could think something so
dark
and so i went to my 12-step group and
told them this dark impulse that i had
and you know the the only reaction you
ever get in a 12-step group is you know
thank you for sharing you know that's it
you know nobody goes oh you're a
horrible human being how could you even
think of some you know it's just thank
you for sharing and and most of the guys
in this group their lives were so
freaking out of control they're probably
thinking that's it that's the worst
that's that's the worst you got to bring
to us so i told them and it was such a
relief to just speak it out loud and
just not carry it around inside of me
where eventually it would have either
kept fueling a lot of shame for having
the impulse or perhaps it might have
even gotten acted on right if i didn't
deal with it and bring it out in the
open so i went to my 12-step group told
them no big negative reaction so i
actually had an appointment with my
therapist
like an hour after the group so i drove
over to her office and i'm thinking same
thing i'm going to tell this female
therapist this dark sexual impulse she's
going to think i'm a terrible human
being blah blah blah but i told her and
just you know i told her the impulse and
she just looked at me with compassion
and said well let's explore what that
story is about
and like i'm going that's it
that's as terrible of reaction as i'm
gonna get so i get done with the therapy
session i'm driving home
my my second wife i used to tell her
that her middle name ought to be
overreact because that's what she did in
every situation and so i'm driving home
to to miss overreact to tell i'm
thinking i gotta tell her i gotta tell
her i you know i think i already told my
12-step group already told my therapist
i'm batting a thousand if i tell her and
she overreacts and has a terrible
reaction to it i'm still 666 great
batting average no problem and so i'm
driving home soothing myself right and
not rehearsing the story because if i'm
just going to tell her the truth i just
got to tell her the truth
and um i get home and i say i got
something i got to talk with you about
took her back to the bedroom we sat on
the bed
and i said um here's the thing i said i
want you to already talk to my 12-step
group or he talked to my therapist
but the thing i want to tell you about
is i had this impulse i didn't act on it
but i had it i've talked about it i've
gotten it out i needed to tell you about
it
and she just looked at me and said
that kind of scares me
it doesn't surprise me
and i'm glad you told me
and she never brought it up again never
reacted never used it against me and i'm
sitting there thinking
this is like magic you know all you have
to do is just reveal just tell and and
you know it's when we're keeping the
secrets and hiding the things that
people sense something is wrong and out
of whack that's what most people are
reacting to is what what doesn't seem
true or aligned and me just sitting down
and saying here's the truth after having
already practiced that with safe people
let me then do it with somebody that i
did have fear that she might have a
negative reaction
and and i'm grateful that she didn't and
that because that helped reinforce i can
keep revealing myself and i can handle
whatever the reaction is that people
might have
yeah that's very interesting i like that
you pointed out it's
the the hidden things that create fear
that people are reacting to it's like
what are you not saying how bad could it
be and i guess if you shove something
down in yourself and you think it's that
bad you're gonna give off those i don't
know that energy that people around you
like look how bad a person i am
even if it's not necessarily that bad
yeah they and they do sense it i mean i
tell men that for example that um and i
found that women are especially
sensitive
to to this energy to repressed energy
they they get it that now i know a lot
of women will like then project what
they think it's about but yeah oh guys
i'll tell guys for example let's say
you're driving down the street with with
your girlfriend or your wife or whatever
and and you've got gas and you don't you
don't want to rip one right there and so
you're repressing you're holding the gas
back you're being a good person a good
citizen right by not ripping a fart you
know while you're driving down the road
but you're repressing something and not
saying anything about it your woman is
sitting there next to you going there's
some up there's something going on with
it he's holding something back he's
repressing something oh i know he was
looking at that woman's breasts on the
corner back there and he's still
thinking about her breasts he's thinking
you know and then the woman will create
this big story and all of a sudden
they're having some big fight because
she'll accuse him of the thing that she
projected and he was just trying to be a
good guy and you know holding hell and
gas back and that goes on all the time
in relationships uh is is one person
holding back and the other person
sensing it
having some visceral reaction to it and
often creating a story to go with it
that's usually a projection of their own
personal story from their own past
experiences and now all of a sudden you
know they're often fighting about
something that didn't even happen
but something was happening that never
got spoken of it's it's the meta thing
most people never really fight about the
thing they're fighting about they're
fighting they're fighting about some
meta type thing but now they're talk
they're arguing about this but it's
usually something different than that